[Musica]
buonasera è fighissimo vedere del
faccione mentre si cammina
per tutti quelli che non hanno idea di
chi io sia io sono pietro
ogni tanto
tendenzialmente da un certo punto della
mia vita ad oggi io sono pietro morello
e questo mi fa sentire un po un pirla
perché
la maggior parte dei miei colleghi che
creano contenuti sui social e che hanno
raggiunto una certa notorietà hanno
inventato dai nickname che sono la fine
del nome del mondo c'è shade se gli
hobby c'è willwosh willie walsh si
chiama guglielmo di nome e io ho sempre
pensato che guglielmo fosse un po più
facile di willwoosh eppure tutti i
ragazzini quando magari ci fermano per
strada per chiedere la foto per
chiacchierare un attimo per interagire
willwoosh lo sanno sempre e arrivano
dall'altra parte della strada
facciamolo avuto un articolato benissimo
nel mio caso spesso invece la scena è un
po diversa eh beh ma tu sei quello
quello che il pianoforte quello che fai
video to say aiutami
pietro
pietro morello
pietro morell pietro morello è un porti
sonante da un e cognome detto così fila
sembra alberto angela però alberto aggio
l'asta quindi entro morello sta qui
nella mia testa e quindi io ho sempre
preferito quel momento sano in cui le
persone mi chiamano pietro e questo
nella maggior parte dei casi succede
quando io esercito quella che è la mia
più grande passione e non che ciò che mi
dà da vivere a livello emotivo ad oggi
ovvero fare musica con i bambini non con
tutti i bambini io amo tutti i bambini
però io faccio musica con quei bambini
che stanno in quelle situazioni che a
pronunciarle fanno venire un po di
amaro in bocca
musica quei bambini in ospedale
nelle baraccopoli
dell'islam le distese di spazzatura
ecco fare musica in quelle situazioni
spesso e volentieri vuol dire raccontare
storie
mettersi lì e con la propria chitarra e
io quando nascono il pescatore di de
andrè racconto di quest'uomo un post ero
segnato dalle rughe che prende la sua
barchetta va in mezzo al lago e va a
pescare all'ombra dell'ultimo sole
oppure racconto della turandot della
mitica principessa turandot e una
fanciulla giapponese meravigliosa che
rifiuta ogni marito e dica pavia la
testa però le mie storie sono
no
mancano mancano di grandi significati
le vere storie che che io cerco di
raccontarmi con la musica e con le
parole sono in realtà il mio essere un
ambasciatore perché sono storie che mi
hanno raccontato i bambini
ei ragazzi sono storie che in confronto
è il vangelo e voce dicono delle cose
allucinanti con delle metano re
dettagliatissime precisissime
adesso vi racconto di una storia che ne
ha mi ha spiegato una bambina che si
chiama beatrice non voglio scendere oggi
in termini medici di malattie perché mi
fanno vivere un po mal di pancia
beatrice è una bimba meravigliosa di 9
anni che alta più o meno come mio fianco
e senza i capelli e e alla flebo
attaccata da un cerottino a forma di
farfalla
un giorno mentre raccontavamo le nostre
storie quindi avevo la mia bella
chitarra e con con il pennarello vetro
grafico quello per le lavagne bianca che
si cancellano i disegniamo le storie e
disegniamo tutto quello che loro
raccontano e ovviamente in beatrice
nella mia testa da persona molto poco
furba ha dedicato una storia banale la
principessa il principe il drago
io ci ho messo un mese a capire che quel
drago era una metafora fatta benissimo
articolata dettagliata della sua
malattia
perché quel drago è pesante e grosso e
quindi mi fa stare a letto perché si
posa sul mio petto
quel drago sputafuoco e quindi in luce
allo stomaco perché la terapia fa
bruciare lo stomaco
quel drago ogni tanto vola via e quindi
io posso alzarmi incamminare però
cacchio io lo so che poi il drago ei e
lì prima o poi torna
ecco beatrice uno scricciolo così ogni
giorno viene da me
sento felice pietro mi chiamano pietro
solo una bambina
e io fesso come una campana dico eh sì
beh se anche bellissima bambina
bellissima andiamo a suonare no io sono
una bambina
io sono una non sono come mia nonna
che ebbe chiesta del letto e non sono
come mio nonno che è vecchio punti in
più di lei stare sta nel letto di fianco
al ed io sono una bambina io corro
e che cacchio dice no a moreno non puoi
correre cioè i fili
e complicato no
no non e complicate facile io sono una
bambina io corro io corro due parole io
corro la dovuta ripetere forse quattro
volte perché io capisci cosa voleva dire
io corro quante facile da dire quanto è
facile da pensare gente noi tutti
corriamo noi corriamo tantissimo però
non corriamo con le gambe noi corriamo
con l'anima parliamo con i pensieri noi
corriamo perché siamo troppo abituati a
dover ricercare una tristezza noi siamo
abituati a cercare un pretesto per
essere tristi per lamentarci ma noi
cacchio siamo delle cose felicissime
noi siamo dei power bank di felicità noi
possiamo possiamo spaccare il mondo con
la felicità che abbiamo dentro
noi siamo dei deficienti perché
manchiamo di semplicità di due parole io
corro non dobbiamo dire io sono felice
sono tre io sono io corro sono due conti
meno più semplice semplifichiamo io
corro ecco il brano che vi sono adesso
il primo dei due che vi suono poi
tornerò qui a raccontarvi il secondo è
mezz'aria
e un brano che non canto perché sono un
po stonato quindi non me la sentivo di
cantare è un brano che ho un po di
difficoltà a suonare così d'amblè perché
molto legato alla mia intimità alla mia
sfera emotiva e un brano che io ho
composto grazie alle parole di beatrice
io corro quindi visto che non lo canto
vi chiedo di immaginare un attimo come
che lo composto io io l'ho composto
pensando a una bambina in centro a un
campo con la pioggia tutto grigio bianco
e nero con la pioggia lei seduta così
che sente che piove addosso e poi un
certo punto smette di piovere
c'è il sole tutto torna colori il prato
verde il cielo azzurro allora beatrice
cosa fa
corre cacchio se corre ecco vado lì è il
vero suono
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ecco io io vi chiedo scusa se ci sono
eventuali errori ma prima ho chiesto
ieri durante le prove di non mettermi il
monitor del pianoforte perché pensavo
fosse un'idea intelligente e poi adesso
non sentivo quello che sfociarono però
adesso vi racconto il secondo brano
il secondo brano ve lo racconto
parlandovi di una bambina un'altra che
si chiama maria
maria noi tutti bene o male nella vita
l'abbiamo pronunciato perché la nostra
maestra delle elementari si chiamava
maria maria grazia carla maria mari e
basta oppure perché una nostra parente
bene o male maria si chiama però questa
maria non ha niente a che fare con
l'italia infatti una bambina che io ho
conosciuto in una baraccopoli al confine
tra la romania e l'ucraina lei vive lì
ecco appena arrivato in questa
baraccopoli
io ero in un container in uno scatolone
di ferro che noi usiamo per fare scuola
non parlavo niente di rumeno non parlavo
niente di quella lingua fantastiche
mirabolante che si è creata nella
baraccopoli che è un misto di lingue ed
ero di fianco a una bimba che si chiama
arte mese e cercavo di farla e colorare
un disegno io sono pure daltonico quindi
proprio ero nel panico i miei colori non
sapevo cosa dirle
maria
otto anni allora
da sola
si alza viene da me tutta un poco mi
prende per mano e torna al manco così in
silenzio perché lei ha capito che io non
parlavo niente si mette tutti i colori
di fronte a sé
e li nomina per farmeli ripetere
porto cavalli
alabastro blanco
per tanto tempo dopo io ho pensato ma io
a vent'anni
che ci avrei pensato nel senso ha
rifatto la stessa cosa mi sarei reso
conto che la persona dall'altra parte
del container 18 anni tutto il diritto
di far ministra cazzi miei di non andare
a guardare cosa fa l'adulto della
situazione non parla ok vado da lui e
glielo spiego io così può aiutare
qualcun altro ecco da lì io e maria
abbiamo stretto un rapporto pazzesca e
mi ha regalato questa piccola collanina
che ho al collo che che ho sempre al
collo io magari volevo anche toglierla
per venire qui perché ho sempre paura di
perderla io perdo una roba del genere
vado fuori non posso toglierlo perché
non mi passa più della testa questo non
perché io abbia avuto una macrocefali a
improvvisa ma perché l'abbiamo legata è
saldata più stretta di quanto non sia la
mia circonferenza della testa questo
perché quando maria me l'ha regalata ha
detto quelle parole che dicono i bambini
che ti no il confronto resi prendere una
caterva di pugni in faccia perché mi ha
detto
finchè questo anello sta al tuo collo
io sto bene
allora l'abbiamo saldata più stretta e
che cosa che ha fatto maria dicendo
quella cosa di maria mi ha fatto capire
quanto sono importanti i simboli
non i simboli noi siamo abituati ai
simboli che si rifanno poi a un fattore
culturale gigantesco prima abbia avuto
don alberto avete presente il crocifisso
no tutti hanno presente corsivisti crede
chi non crede cattolici buddisti
protestanti tutti sanno cos'è il
crocifisso è bene o male incute anche
perché è enorme è un simbolo che è un
concetto culturale gigantesco legato di
no il simbolo di maria e un anellino che
sappiamo io e lei che adesso pure voi
ma è un simbolino
e marina quindi così mi ha spiegato
quanto importante innamorarsi
innamorarsi di un simbolo innamorarsi di
un palco rosso innamorarsi delle persone
che ti ascoltano innamorarsi di una
situazione innamorarsi
infatti il brano che adesso vi suono si
chiama filosofia e nessuno solo un pezzo
perché il lunghissimo e il filosofia
parla di questo sento senza le parole
solo con i pensieri parla dell'amore per
la cultura del lavoro e per la
conoscenza dell'amore per la collana
dell'amore per sofia filosofia parla di
tutto questo ecco quindi adesso io torno
di a suonar velo e poi ti ringrazio dopo
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]